madame la première ministre
madame la présidente chers collègues
nous n'avons au nom du groupe écologiste
que 10 minutes à nous partager avec ma
co président de série le châtelain c'est
c'est bien peu et j'ai bien conscience
que notre avis vous indiffère puisque
vous avez refusé de vous soumettre aux
biens légitimes vote de confiance aussi
j'irai à l'essentiel madame la première
ministre nous n'aurions pas voté la
confiance évidemment car nous n'avons
aucune raison de vous faire confiance au
vu des cinq années écoulées au contraire
nous exprimons de la défiance la
défiance sur les sujets climatique est
lié à l'effondrement du vivant cyrielle
châtelain on a parlé vous n'avez rien
fait au point d'être doublement condamné
par la justice pour une action
climatique et au point de plonger notre
jeunesse dans une angoisse existentielle
heureusement les écologistes héritiers
de rené dumont sont de retour et dans
les pas de noël mamère ou de cécile
duflot il faudra compter avec nous
croyez-moi le climat ne sera plus traité
comme un sujet annexe
défiance sociale car les politiques
publiques injuste que vous avez menées
ont affaibli les services publics
et accru les inégalités au point de
disloquer le pays
défiance démocratique puisque nous vous
devons malheureusement la présence sur
ces bancs de 90 députés d'extrême droite
c'est le fruit d'un long travail de
banalisation de leur discours de votre
part vous qui vous présentiez comme un
rempart et qui n'avait pas voulu choisir
entre nos candidats ceux de la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale
vos opposants et les adversaires éternel
de la république c'est une faute
extrêmement lourde de vous être fait mon
parent par mes marchepied de l'extrême
droite dans cette institution
défiance à l'égard de ce nouveau gou
nouveau gouvernement défiance quand on
voit que le garde des sceaux mis en
examen
mis en examen est reconduit dans ses
fonctions faisant de nous la risée des
démocraties modernes défiance à l'égard
de monsieur darmanin mais reconduit
ministre de l'intérieur alors qu'il
qualifie ses opposants d'ennemis et
alors qu'à l'occasion
des événements du stade de france il a
démontré son entière entière
incompétence en matière de maintien de
l'ordre
défiance quand nous voyons monsieur
béchu nommé ministre de la transition
écologique on le connaît plus pour ses
positions réactionnaires son opposition
au mariage pour tous aux campagnes anti
sida dans sa ville plutôt évidemment que
pour le combat contre le dérèglement
climatique et contre les néonicotinoïdes
ces pesticides tueurs d'abeilles
défiance enfin parce que jusqu'ici vous
n'avait envoyé aucun signal de votre
volonté concrète de saisir cet immense
opportunité cette immense cadeau que
nous on fait les françaises et les
français
cette proportionnelle par effraction
cette absence de majorité absolue qui
peut permettre enfin peut-être de sortir
des postures de la majorité comme de
celles de l'opposition
mon grand père raoul bayou députés s est
fille aux places 560 71 disait déjà il
ya 60 ans
la majorité ces fermes là l'opposition
c'est cause toujours
soixante ans après rien n'a changé et la
situation s'est même aggravée sous le
précédent quinquennat
et pourtant la nouvelle configuration
pourrait nous laisse peut laisser
espérer que les choses changent cela ne
tient qu'à vous et j'en doute
nous nous battrons pour faire
appliquer les accords de paris et la
mise en oeuvre de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat nous serons
toujours moteur pour avancer sur les
questions de climat et de justice
sociale je ne vais prendre qu'un seul
exemple la sur taxation des profits des
pétro gazier ces multinationales ces
nouvelles profiteuse de guerre
profiteuse de la crise écologique qui
s'enrichissent sur le dos des plus
démunis sur taxons les voilà ce que nous
allons proposer que chacun paie sa juste
part voilà l'urgence que les surprofits
des pollueurs soient surtaxés et
reversée aux plus vulnérables voilà la
transition écologique dans la justice
sociale
madame la première ministre la
configuration de cette assemblée c'est
pas une crise c'est une chance à la
majorité relative je dis
n'ayez pas peur du débat n'ayez pas peur
des compromis assumés de descendre de
votre piédestal d'en finir avec vos
certitudes d'écouter les corps
intermédiaires les associations les
syndicats les autorités indépendantes
qui vous disent l'état du pays sortez du
déni et reconnaissait enfin l'urgence
d'agir pour le climat saisissez cette
opportunité de faire progresser la
démocratie pour notre part nous
écologistes nous y sommes prêts est
prête en résumé madame la première
ministre chaque fois que vous
poursuivrez vos politiques climaticides
de casse sociale et de recul
démocratique vous nous trouverez sur
votre chemin combatif et déterminé et
chaque fois que vous déciderez d'agir
pour le climat et contre les inégalités
vous nous trouverez nous les écologistes
prêt est prête pour voter ces avancées
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]